au sommaire le sentier de la source
manouille à salazi la curiosité de la
semaine la maison folio à
elbourg direction le fond du cirque de
Salazie après avoir atteint elbour
continué en direction d'ilat avidot à
cette Inter section la source manouille
est indiquée sur votre gauche vous
pourrez vous garer au départ du
sentier pour cette randonnée de 6 km en
aller-retour prévoir de quoi vous
protéger du soleil et de la pluie des
vivres et une réserve
d'eau la source ou les sources
manouilles ont été découvertes par
hasard en 1916 par un un jeune de
Salazie qui leur a laissé son nom ce
sont des sources chaudes férugineuses
situées dans la ravine dans laquelle la
rivière du M prend naissance pour les
rejoindre la randonnée en aller-retour
depuis hat avidot est la solution la
plus
facile une première montée assez raide
de 300 m permet une bonne mise en jambe
un sentier régulièrement traversé par de
petits cours d'eau dans une ambiance
agréable l'ensoleillement important de
ce versant exposé au nord a tout
toutefois favoriser le développement de
nombreuses espèces exotiques jolie à
regarder mais
envahissante l'arrivée au kiosque en
bordure du plateau de terre plate permet
de réaliser une première PAE et de
profiter d'un beau panorama sur le
cirque de salazi on voit justement le
village d'bourg qui est posé sur le
produit de l'érosion du cirque donc on
voit c'est bad l c'est mauvaise terre et
donc ces terre qui sont éboulés de du
rempart tel qu'on le voit par exemple
ici donc on a le plateau de terre plate
avec ses cryptoméas et juste à la base
de ce plateau on voit déjà la terre qui
qui s'érode donc qui
s'ffrite planté en 1956 sur plus de 110
hectares la forêt de cryptomeria de
terre plate est l'une des plus
importantes de l'île espèce exotique non
envahissante le cryptomeria a été
introduit dans les années 50 pour
organiser une filière bois à la Réunion
bois à croissance rapide il est
principalement utilisé en
menuiserie
aujourd'hui confidentielle
l'exploitation des forêts de cryptomeria
par l'ONF estoué à disparaître
progressivement au profit de la
reforestation
indigène arrivé en bord de rempart on
surplombe la ravine de la rivière du
c'est le moment de descend dans la
ravine en pleine forêt primaire
changement d'ambiance
radical au loin les cascades qui
s'écoulent du massif du python des
neiges difficile d'imaginer que cette
même forêt était à la place des
cryptomeras de terre plat il y a
seulement un demi-siècle après une
centaine de mètres de descente sans
difficulté le sentier rejoint le fond de
ravine face au Sentier des fractures
sont visibles sur la paroi c'est d'ici
que remonte une partie des eau de la
source manouille chargé en calcaire ces
eaux sont dites pétrifiantes car elles
permettent la fossilisation des plantes
à l'entour elles sont également
fortement chargées en fer ce qui
explique la couleur rouge ocre déposée
sur les matières
calcaires un lieu agréable idéal pour
piqueniquer avant de revenir sur ses
pas c'estando qui est très courte
comparé à d'Es sur le cirque en 1h de on
peut arriver sur les fameuses sur la
fameuse source manouille et en très peu
de temps on peut voir un changement dans
le paysage donc une diversité dans la
progression sur le sentier on a le temps
qui peut se couvrir donc quand on fait
une marche assez rapide dans un circle
pour voir les paysages il rien de mieux
et cette marche là c'est parfaitement
enfin c'est parfait pour ça quoi il y a
deux variantes ouais donc on a le côté
terrain hbourg donc où c'est plus pentu
il y a un peu plus de dénivelé et cette
variante qu'on vient de faire
aujourd'hui donc par lataavdot ça permet
de découvrir justement le l'ilatavdot où
la plupart des randonneurs bah le
connaissent plus pour aller vers le
Pison d'chin ou la traverser de grand
sable donc là c'est une petite marche
accessible par ilataavidot donc ce que
j'aime pas dans cette randonnée c'est
l'aspect anthopisé de du sentier
c'est-à-dire que on voit que c'est
proche de la civilisation on a des
plantes qui ont été ramenées par l'homme
donc il se sont installés dans dans ce
milieu dans où dans lequel la forêt
primaire existait auparavant et donc du
coup ce de tiers de ce sentier c'est que
des espèces exotiques envahissantes
c'est sur la fin où là on va vraiment
prendre plein la vue au niveau de cette
forêt primaire avec une diversité
d'espèces endémique d'espèces de pied de
bois pays
quoi
en plein cœur du village classé de
hbourg cette vieille bâtiste créole
typique d' est ouverte aux visiteurs
depuis une quinzaine d'années avec son
mobilier longtemps et son jardin fourni
la maison folio est notre curiosité de
la
semaine nous sommes àbourg donc à la
maison folio dans la maison familiale
c'est une maison qui a donc 143 ans
maison qui a été constru à l'époque où
elbourg était une station thermale ou
que tous les notables bourgeois venaient
monter prendre bien sûr l'AR frais et se
en même temps fréquenter le gouverneur
qui a été aussi c'eston qu' visite
depuis 1995 exactement maison qui donc
est typique architecture créole faite
entièrement en bois de fer et en grandat
principalement avec un mobilier d'époque
aussi jardin créol le dirait le jardin
typique dire fouille de plantation sans
ornements particuliers avec bien sûr
partie florale partie importante dite
plante à parfum épice
médicinal moi ce qui me dans ça à cette
maison c'est que bon c'est vrai que
j'ai j'ai peux pas dire que je suis pas
né ici mais c'est vrai que j'y habite
j'ai pris mes repères j'ai et puis j'y
travaille puis c'est vrai que je suis
dans un cadre je pense que beaucoup
doivent m'envier malgré tout quand on
parle de HQ des bâtiments modernes jeais
que les anciens ils avaient compris
c'est quoi le
HQ